what's Happ it's your boy Fredo bang be
me rock Baby D scar name is talk money
make no sense to speak you can catch me
on the bootleg Hill podcast let go what
the hey about to get into a new
interview want to shout out to our
sponsor Imperial they're giving you a
free that's right free 2 G top shelf
pre-roll with the glass tip that's right
delivered right to your door all right
it's free all you got to do is pay
shipping use the promo code boot leg at
Imperial
extraction. there's a 1.5 G of Premium
flour plus a half a gram of thca
diamonds loaded up in this thing and
guess what you could get one for free
with the promo code bootle go to
Imperial extraction. comom it's free you
just pay shipping let's get into the
interview ble C podcast special guest
let's get his mic
right my guy Fredo bang is back on the
show finally it's been a while man yeah
been a couple of years good to see you
bro they been a little minute H yeah it
was uh I think the last time you on the
Pod it was like it was definitely two
years ago at least it was I think it was
right maybe like a few months before you
got locked up the last time yeah two
years so yeah what's up how's how's
everything man getting ready for the new
project yeah yes I'm sad yes I'm sad
explain so B
basically uh well there's two reasons
why I named it that all the music that's
on this project I made when I was going
through a real rough time in my life
last since I've been out of jail okay
and also it's basically like it's like a
iron and thing it's like basically
showing you okay we can make regular
music and be sad as hell yeah you get
what I'm saying also thank you for that
because I feel like I'm tired of just
like I just feel like hip-hop needs to
be a little more vulnerable yeah be a
little more honest yeah you know what I
mean so when you say cuz cuz cuz it
takes a first of all to name your album
that that's a big that's a that's a
brave thing to do you know what I'm
saying where you going back and forth
about doing it cuz to be like that
vulnerable publicly you know and and
you're kind of seen as like a quote
unquote gangster rapper you know what
I'm
saying
oh it was either
that um I forgot what the other name
was I forgot what the other name was but
it was mainly that one what was uh what
about the last couple of years had you
in a low Place uh it was just going to
jail for nothing and U when I went to
jail you know I was at the top of my
career for real so for sure it super
slowed me down I had to refund shows I
had to just basically like I had to just
restart everything on some on some [__]
you know what I'm saying cuz you lose
your you know it's it's like you lose
that that flow you know what I'm saying
so just redoing that and then I had uh
labor problems with my main with my uh
independent labor so I couldn't put put
out no projects I haven't put out a
project in 14 months I was about to say
it's been a minute it's been at least a
year yeah but it's not my fault you feel
me so it's just so cuz for people who
don't know you're well I don't know if
you still are you still on Def Jam yeah
okay so you had a uh a label that that
deal was through like your OG label
right from was that from Baton Rouge n
okay but just like an independent label
that yeah so cuz this Rich Homie Quan
went through something similar with uh
TIG okay where they prevented him from
releasing music for years right um so
what was uh what was the disagreement
and how did it end up getting
resolved basically
uh they had a legal situation with a
third another part that kept them uh
back from handling business with me
properly and so it just was tied up
crisscross and just just deeper getting
worse and worser you know what I'm
saying and we just couldn't settled it
for a while what ended up being the
resolution like what was the The Tipping
Point I don't get too too deep but I got
say I don't fault them all the way
because you know stuff happens [__]
happens right people um you know don't
like you said like sometimes just my
biggest thing was I felt
like um like they they they helped me
get to where I am I wouldn't be where
I'm at without them but I feel like as
the artist I am the initiatives that I
take as much as work I put in on behalf
of both of us I feel like you know what
I'm saying sometimes you gotta swallow
the pill for me you feel me because I do
the same for you you feel me so I just
feel like what I was going through I
shouldn't have been going through even
for that long right I feel like should
immediately got fixed what would be
advice because we've seen recently
similar situations like Megan and uh
1501 I think it was 151 Carl Crawford
they went through it if you're a young
upand cominging artist um
um sometimes people can come into your
life and and like you said make things
possible for you right when you don't
got nothing so you're just like hey
let's do it but is there any sort of
things people should look out for or
things people should do to kind of
protect themselves from getting into a
situation where that you've that you
kind of like learned from this situation
I'm going say no matter what you do and
precautions that you
take how the music industry is set up
and it's not because of just the labels
it's just how [__] be going right it's
so easy for us artist to get [__] out
of our money like that's just plain and
simple it's just easy you know what I'm
saying it's not sit in law that this has
to happen that has to happen sometimes
um like with lods I even got lods that's
something I tell everybody get direction
letter Direction and make sure what's
owed to you get paid to you and what get
owed to everybody else go to them so
nobody get collecting somebody money and
they got to wait for them to pay them I
got those but my [__] still messed up to
where it couldn't get put in and and fix
you feel me so for people who don't know
what a letter of direction is it could
be I'm not like a music lawyer it's just
a signed document saying that it's it's
also how you can like distribute Masters
too like so for example that's that's
old way though but let's say you put
album out right your l or like your lods
would be sent to Def Jam So Def Jam
knows who to pay before it hits like
yeah someone else's pockets and you got
to depend on that person to do right by
you and see this the thing like it's
Death Jam is the publishing side BMI cuz
there's so many different sides of the
music it's a lot you know what I'm
saying got the writer side and you got
the publishing side so that's two right
there you got Death Jam you got the
people who collect the pub they got the
police people who may collect YouTube
separately they got [__] Sound
Exchange like all of it it's too it's a
lot bro so who do you depend on because
people I see people getting taken
advantage on by lawyers too like you
also got to kind of make sure you got
you hire the right lawyer yeah I didn't
went through that too cuz like I didn't
hire lawyers that don't even do [__] and
then and they get a cut for nothing it's
like hey you know I could have probably
just Google this contract
online I mean it seems like I mean I
most people don't know about the things
we're speaking about most artists yeah
so for you you kind of had to go through
it to be like I mean this ain't going to
happen that's the only time really as
artist learn cuz like I'm saving to [__]
you feel me and I'm a type of person
where I read [__] three four times like
all my contracts I looked at I go over I
wait until I sign them you know what I'm
saying but sometimes you just don't
fully you know what I'm saying
understand until you go through it you
feel me and then you learn and the next
go around it's different you go around
you get it right would you say you're
happy with Death Jam so far
uh I'm happy in my position yeah uh I
feel like it's always could be better um
I can't F Death Jam for a lot of things
because they are they a for one they a
legendary label so 100% what comes with
with that though is a old horse oh yeah
you feel me so and I'm a very new horse
you feel me so sometimes it's very hard
for those old horses to to break habit
old habits you get what I'm saying U
also
um it's it's a bunch of new people still
of coming in you feel me well that's
what I was going to say since you've
been signed to Death Jam there's been
reg regime changes at the label we had
like three different presid
right and that I I always feel like if
let's say the president who is there
when you're signed they're going to be
the most excited about you cuz they're
responsible for your signing right or
the anr whoever whoever brought you into
Death Jam right right once they leave
it's up in the air whether or not the
person who replaces them Paul Rosenberg
one who brought me in aign me shout out
to Paul yeah Eminem's manager Goliath
entertainment a legend but it always
like I see it happen all the time time
where somebody will get brought into a
label situation and then once their
whole Squad that brought them in leaves
and goes to a different label and then
there's a whole new people and then
they're not as enthusiastic about it or
they don't understand it as well yeah
the good thing with me is uh and shout
out to the president like T I [__] with
tund t there right now great guy and he
a very understanding he for the artist
like 100% he's he's solid about as solid
as they come yeah and it's hard coming
in trying to fix everything you feel me
uh the thing with me
is
I'm pretty different from a lot of
artists I don't wait on the label to cut
the check to go get the videos done you
just handle it I handle it and I wait to
get it later so and and then you you you
you'll file like a reimbursement right
so out the gate I'm productive yeah for
two I'm very budget Savvy you know what
I'm saying like I'm I'm not going
[__] to go get a $50,000 video that I
don't need and cuz you can spend three
and I don't feel like it's going to make
back you know what I'm saying and I have
projects that are in the green already
which nobody has right on major label
systems it's very tough and if if I
could if I can push I pushed out what
three four certifications a bunch of
Chans with Dev jam with three different
prent all this stuff going on what if
everything was consistent right so
everybody knows my worth you know what
I'm saying that's interesting yeah cuz
for people who don't know like if you're
an artist I think a lot of times and and
I'm one of the top streamers over there
you know what I'm saying no shade I want
to shout you out too because I think
you're in a good position at Def Jam
because right
now Def Jam needs a star yeah they don't
have like YG Left Big Sean's like
midcycle like you know uh I know Benny
the butcher's about to drop his album
but like I feel like Def Jam like you're
the young star on the label now which
can only help you because they need it
like they really like that it's kind of
cold over there you know what I'm saying
in terms of like when you compare them
to like Republic or you compare them to
oscope or you know what I'm saying
Capital RCA but um it's it's funny you
say that your budget Savvy because you
know I always tell artists cuz I have a
recording studio so I was tell artists
like hey I got the big Studio vocal
chain and it's $70 an hour right but
that's f a 70 an hour with an engineer
right but but don't give me the the
label invoice [__] pay for the studio
otherwise they're going to send you to
Paramount or they're going to send you
to like you know one of these big it's
250 an hour with an engineer no I I do
pay I do pay sometimes only time I would
I won't is if I'm locking in for like
two three weeks and I got FK cuz
sometimes I that's what I'm saying
people people you know there's people
who come to LA and they'll stay in the
studio for like a week straight and I'm
like bro you know how much that week
yeah cost you and and you're over here
ordering [__] BOS
NOA cuz it when it when it come to me
bringing four five producers in flights
so it's a lot more money involved so
just so they know I'm not on some trying
to eat at my budget type cuz some some
weird people do that and I don't know
why they do that cuz you just taking
money that you got to pay back well
those artists they live off advances
they don't that's there's a lot of
artists I know who they're like hey man
they give you get that advance and you
don't ever think you're going to see
another red scent off that album yeah so
it's like I got to get the next album
done turn it why I get my you know half
a million or whatever it is that's
that's dope you got you got a bunch of
music in the green cuz that's not a
common practice with a lot of young
artists cuz they [__] that budget off
yeah I mean and it's hard the the cut is
very hard to get in the green like your
music got have to do good and your
budget has to be low to get in the green
fast what uh was something that you were
able to like do to kind of get out of
the funk you were in um because you had
so much momentum and you still I mean
look it's not like you don't have
momentum like yeah it's just but you you
had to was on the radio everywhere I be
wanting more out myself no but I'm
saying like how were you able to pull
yourself out of that and just kind of
like did it kind of like make you
hungrier like you get out of jail are
you like super [__] laser focused or
you just a little discouraged at first
so when I got out of jail I had to go
through a process of the rest of my
papers mhm so at first they wouldn't let
me go back home to my house I about to
had to get a new house so it was just in
Florida or in Baton R in Florida they
would let let me go back at first so I
it's just there so many things I had to
go through so my mind wasn't all the way
focused and like I said I forgot my
rhythm so now I'm trying to fix I'm
taking so long to try to fix the labor
issues I'm not focused on getting my
music out right by any means necessary
you know what I'm saying and so it's
just I I wasn't focused and right now
and when when you do get off focus you
got to find that confidence again cuz
you feel me like that's when the people
don't realize it's almost like when
you're basketball player and that shots
not going in you just got to shoot
yourself out of the [__] right right and
so then that's when the comment start
getting to you though that's when it
start [__] with you you know what I'm
saying so do you find yourself reading
comments yeah I read I read everything I
watch I watch everything you got to stop
noop read the reason why I don't is
because I want that good or bad you know
what it is though you got here doing you
unapologetically yeah what's going to
happen is you you you you spend too much
time reading the comments even if you
don't think it's affecting you
subconsciously yeah it's affecting you
subconsciously you'll think of that one
bro the you got to understand the type
of human beings that leave comments on
YouTube videos and like these posts
[__] NE hurt my bad like imagine S
Flex he said man this [__] heavy my neck
hurt um no but imagine like I always
tell this to people like you know cuz
like I have a YouTube channel and
sometimes I'll get stuck reading the
comments and I be like damn someone left
a paragraph under this video they took
three five minutes out of their day yeah
to to comment on a stranger piece of
content something negative like imagine
like how [__] up in your days got to
be or your life got to be it'll be
sometimes it could be like it'll be a
troll but it'll be funny to me and
sometimes it'll brighten up my day
sometimes it make me mad you know what
I'm saying it just yeah like if I if
something ever comes across my Twitter
timeline that's negative I just retweet
it yeah because I don't give a [__] yeah
I just like [__] yeah don't let the
comments get to you bro I would stop
reading them mon that [__] ain't good
for your health what is good for your
health these days mushrooms I'm I got a
lot this a mental that's the mental drug
and stuff huh it'll help you yeah I mean
you are you still on papers n oh you're
not I finally got off good
congratulations man five years congrats
yeah that's got to feel like yeah that
that was like I said that was another
process I was going through through so
now that you're not on probation it's
almost like I can go out the and
everything you could do what you want
now man and like leave that whole part
of your life just in the rearview mirror
like you know what I'm saying like
there's other bags to get now yeah now
you could go is there a country that I
went to Bahamas and uh got my first out
out the country check how was it it it
was beautiful I love The Mamas I I get a
house out there yeah for sure now you
just got to like travel for fun hey I
got a week off I'm going to take I'm
going to go see that's the thing like
fun don't really exist in my life right
now cuz I'm grinding Alum yeah feel me
yeah well once the album's out once you
once the videos drop the singles are out
I'm not going to be happy until I just
get into a Groove that is way just more
less stressful as far as like is this
going to do good you know what I'm
saying for sure until I get back into
that group to where I feel like I can't
I I feel like I can't miss then well I
think too like another thing is like
nowadays just because something
doesn't hit the way you thought it was
going to hit just keep going yeah
because lot a lot of times we put out
[__] and then it catch up later on like
trust issues is gold now right when I
first put that out it had like 70,000
views the first week and you were
probably like damn I thought that bro
the J song with 21 Savage the surround
sound that song's a year and a half old
for real yeah the the ceiling challenge
song yeah that song is from early last
year yeah or no early 2022 for real and
it popped up again in 2023 because of
Tik Tok that's how it would be doing
it'll be go viral on Tik Tok or
something that's what I'm saying like
you never know like just and then also
like you're you're you're smart enough
to understand like catalog like matters
so it's like hey I you know whatever you
put up it just it's just going to add to
the catalog speaking of catalog would
you ever uh see yourself in a position
one day to like a lot of people are
selling their catalog selling their Pub
I don't think you're there yet but like
let's say five I got offer from my Pub a
thousand times oh you have not
interested no not ready I be liking my
chicks yeah now if they come with
something just outrageous and then it
doesn't have nothing to do with the
music I'm making for it then you know it
just it just depends on you know what
I'm saying cuz Pub mostly uh includes
like radio and stuff yeah so you got to
think and top still getting paid all you
feel now if I get to the point where I
feel like okay I I done juice this [__]
do songs as much as I can on radio and
stuff let me go ahead and and move
forward you know what I'm saying then uh
I was going to say for you like uh
somebody who is like kind of was broken
like on YouTube and the streaming world
how important cuz you you've had a radio
hit which not a lot of people have had
in your position cuz they're streaming
success and then once you get a radio
hit it's just a little different I get a
lot of radio nice nice radio play lot of
radio support well I was going to say
like when when you get one of them ones
that like is like a top 10 at Urban you
know what I'm saying and I think I think
uh top was
top 20 at Rhythm it got it got top 15 on
Urban and I think maybe 21 19 Rhythm
yeah but when you get one of those like
that's got to feel good to like get in
the car that's my first time ever
feeling like a real rapper right cuz
then you're doing you're going around
you got to go see the every every city
you got to go see the DJ you got to go
the program director time it was just
I'm I'm a numbers person so I'm I'm the
artist that I have my artist access to
every single outlet of my music so I
know exactly what my music doing in
every different spot my numbers so when
top came out and that [__] just I like
oh you feel I so this is what a radio
check look like you feel me the pub
going a whole different way all type of
[__] so hey we got to stop the interview
real quick man shout out to our family
at my bookie NFL season is winding down
you still got some regular season uh
games you can get in on of course the
college bowl games are coming up so much
money to get plus the cash priz is going
down in their weekly blackjack tourn T
at
mybookie.ag and uh this is what's going
on right uh my bookie is crazy cuz
they're doing this if you sign up right
now at mybookie use the promo code
bootleg all right claim your deposit
match redeemable up to $1,000 that's
right they're going to match your first
deposit up to
$1,000 using the promo code bootleg
claim your bonus NFL college bowl game
so much going on in terms of what you're
trying to get down with if you want to
gamble if you want to bet all right they
got Blackjack they got roulette they got
it all uh and of course the best odds
anywhere online when it comes to your
sports betting needs so one more time
sign up right now with that promo code
bootle um and I'm going to tell
everybody this uh you're going to get
your first deposit match up to
$1,000 I'mma put my money I'm feeling
good about the 49ers future BET right
now slam the ners to win the Super Bowl
I think they're taking that whole [__]
bet anytime anywhere with my bookie hey
uh thank you for watching also shout out
to kingp geez I'm just swimming in King
pom but uh we got a shout out to our
good Folks at bluechew that's right
bluechew.com man New Year time to get
that uh that dick of yours in order
maybe you're dealing with the rectile
dysfunction stress at work maybe you're
married 30 years into the marriage it's
a little hard to get it up for a wifey
over there but you want to you know
smash her uh down take her to pound town
real quick for the anniversary what I
suggest you do is [__] with some
bluechew that's right blue Chu what is
it does it work first of all of course
it works yes it does work I've used it
it's great uh with that being said blue
CH it is the same active ingredient as
Viagra and Calis all right trust me oh
they hit all right in a nice chewable
form yeah and it gets delivered straight
to your doorstep discret packaging you
don't got to worry about going to a
doctor's appointment sitting in an
office and speaking with some stranger
about the issues with your Johnson it's
all online all online if you're asking
what I don't know man this sounds like I
don't know I you know how much is it
what do we got to do to get it look it's
free that's right free you can get your
first month of bluechew for free right
now all right your dick deserves it
whoever's taking your dick deserves it
it's be honest all right so go to
blue.com use the promo code bootleg
right now and guess what your first
month will be delivered for free all you
got to do is pay $5 shipping blu.com
promo code leg get your first month for
free delivered right to your doorstep
and thank me later all right let's get
back to the interview who all do you got
on this album U I got Rick Ross I got uh
Rob 49 shout out to Rob great guy I told
a lot of people about ride before he
popped
off uh
treated I got um Kevin gates gates yeah
hey bat Rouge Legend yeah face have you
hung out with him yet no yeah he's a
very uh interesting person he's
interested man but he in in the best way
possible I feel like he's so like
spiritually awoken now you just be
hanging out with him and he just just he
just got energy pouring out of him you
know what I'm saying I like to catch his
shows that I can just to get CU his
shows have a good energy his live shows
are crazy homie's jumping around and I
feel like he's just doing burpees his
whole set that [__] is in so he
he's he's like ripped now and [__] yeah
yeah we're doing a show with him I got a
drive to Phoenix tonight cuz uh the
station I'm on out there is like it's
like our big radio show and he's
headlined so I'm looking forward to his
set shout out to Kevin Gates I think I
seen that fly I got I got a couple more
people on there right yeah it's it's
it's a pretty random show but it's Kevin
Gates Tech 9 young nudy yeah yeah nudy
and Jord Lucas yeah I did seen it I've
seen it uh give me the dynamic between
Rob 49's obviously from uh New Orleans
from New Orleans obviously Baton Rouge
and New Orleans I feel like historically
The Vibes have been different musically
cuz I there two different worlds two
different worlds two different places
I've never I've only driven through
Baton Rouge never hung out I've hung out
New Orleans a couple times um what is
the relationship between the two places
today and you know I think it's dope to
see you guys working together but like I
feel like there should be more like you
know pollination of the of everybody
kind of rocking with each other you know
what I'm
saying so Louisiana is a real crab crab
in a bu bucket type of place so um Baton
Rouge New Orleans we always like had
weird relationships rival kind of like
the Bay La yeah it's like it's like not
a serious rivalry but right it's a
rivalry though yeah you know say B have
a rivalry it's like when it Katrina
happened in New Orleans came to Baton
Rouge and people living out like
everybody was fighting killing each
other all type of stuff you feel me it's
just two different worlds um uh I think
New Orleans is more uh has a more
variety of cultures that uh influence
them uh ju but that's because it's it's
it's been a port right it's a bigger
city yeah you feel me it's [__]
football team it's a trade City you feel
me so you always have people coming in
coming out and and influencing them you
know what I'm saying that's why they
have more cultural stuff than us you
feel me that's fair um I thought what I
thought was dope was like they second
line we on second
line interesting yeah you feel me like
just different stuff like yeah I I need
to go hang out with Baton Rouge uh it
really ain't nothing in bat and Rouge I
heard the I heard the food's good though
I was going to say the food yeah I was
invited to do like uh is it crawfish
season crawfish ball no there's um
somebody had told me to go out there
with them uh there's like a season in
which you like can hunt crawfish out
there or like they're out and you just
grab like raw crawfish everywhere yeah
you could do that in a random
Pond yeah see my thing is I don't like
crawfish like that I like the meat but I
don't like the [__] be sucking
the heads off and [__] pause big pause
big super back to back pause amazing I
mean do you like
crawfish yeah absolutely yeah yeah I
don't know man they're very like like
you said they're in ponds like yeah like
you can go grab a like certain time of
the year you can go grab uh a crawfish
out of
ditch this is true uh what was it like
did you win Ros link when you were in
Miami we been look a couple times but
with the put us on yeah n Su T yeah cuz
I had got a feature for him from my uh
he lives in Atlanta but you live in my
yeah somebody who used to be my artist I
had got a verse for him from Ross and
then we end up sending you end oh okay
okay okay what's that like like trying
to do the label thing as an artist who's
still bubbling and on the come up
yourself u i I'm kind of s with it right
now cuz I just had a just bad Fallout
with my ex artist but I'm I think I
should just focus on myself you're right
cuz people just don't work like you and
it's just people just
don't understand the business sometimes
and and some people just
don't I don't know they they heart just
don't be in the right places sometimes I
also feel like artists
sometimes if you're not like I feel like
the guy who's like the golden standard
is like Gotti cuz Gotti had a 20-year
run and and like you know he always had
CN G you know what I'm saying but like I
feel like he really had so much he had
like solidified his position as like a
top dog before he really really dug into
the label side so was like I feel like
if you're an artist that's like still
kind of working on like solidifying
yourself like it's kind of hard for you
to
like worry about so much at the same
time cuz you're worry about it's
definitely hard cuz it's so much mental
you only have so much mental band you
got to take care of your stuff and and
take care of that stuff it's like trying
to turn in two projects at the same time
and you also kind of feel like you got
to kind of B if the other artists work
at the game like yours you feel like
you're kind of babysitting you got to
tell hey man when you going to drop
something when you you know what you you
can't want it more than they want it
right so yeah damn what's the sound of
this album the new single's Dope by the
way for real oh you come through yeah
it's dope yeah yeah I you know I shot
that back last year March oh so that's a
that's a old old video yeah I just never
dropped it wow that's like months ago I
be having Stu already ready yeah cuz I
was going to my the situation had got so
bad to where I was going to drop the
album myself just [__] it and yeah and
just deal with whatever happened damn
but I Ain want to go through the so this
album was the album for the most part
you were going to say [__] it I'mma drop
the [__] myself yeah this is yeah
exactly oh [__] so this is dope so
you've already had you probably already
got all the visuals [__] ready to go
you've already had I'm working on my
next
project I bet yeah no you got you can't
you can't sit on your hands like you did
with the last album with because of the
legal situation right um what about are
you doing anything with your money like
are you investing or you doing anything
outside of just like you know typical
[__] having nice cars and yeah I I'm
not a big spinner though I'm not into
all that like cuz I've put so much of my
money back into my project yeah so like
for one project I might spend to $80
$100,000 on just videos and stuff yeah
you know what I'm saying so I'm more way
more safer than a lot of people plus I
have a mortgage and kids and stuff like
that how many kids you got I got two two
kids fatherhood something that has
changed you for the better yeah I bet
it's just only the negative side of it
for me is having to overly care about I
have to I have to care about you know
what I'm saying well I have to but I
care more about no you have to I mean
you don't have to yeah I'm just saying
but I care more about somebody else now
besides you right you feel me which
which is a new feeling right yeah so my
work could get put on the back burner
sometimes but yeah if your kid sick or
something cuz it's a double negative
because okay yes I love my child with
all my heart but if I miss work and
don't work you know can't support I
can't support you I'm around you all the
time you feel me I can't make money it's
called work life balance bro yeah you
got to figure that out so I miss a lot
of stuff but you know I just as long as
you're there for enough of it yeah I
just hope that they understand when they
get older oh I'm sure they do for sure
man um are you like a big uh are you
like a big LSU football guy yeah yeah
what do you think of that the
quarterback is supposed to be like a top
five pick did you watch football this
year yeah what's Southern college
football's different bro like y'all
treat that [__] like it's [__] like
religion bro yeah I mean LSU is in my
hood so I'm just like isn't it really
like religion type level dedication like
when it comes to like the LSUS of the
world and the Auburn and the Alabama
like these like man y'all are crazy bro
yeah I don't know it's different and
then it's so funny to me cuz I always
see these videos like Southern College
football fans that are obviously
racist unless it's Saturday yeah and
then they got to root for the black
players
yeah no like I'm out tripping right
that's a lot of them can't stand black
people and then except on Sat on
football day what's up buddy hey what's
up man run Bama
run no that's funny what else what else
you doing these days just to like like
extra like if are you watching TV
playing video games what are you doing
in your spare time video games this been
my like just ease my mind type of time
been playing a lot of MLB really the
show yeah I haven't played the show in
like I was playing GTA and stuff but
it's played it [__] my computer up I
had to get a new computer oh you're on
the computer you're on the PC yeah RP or
you do the role playing yeah in Grizzly
World oh you're in Grizzly World yeah
well I haven't been in like three months
I'm about to get back in for people who
don't know T Grizzly has a the biggest
server fire and if you're in the game
you have to it's like acting you can't
be you can't be yourself you can't break
character you can't break your character
so if you broke character in grizzly
world what happens I think you get like
a war you get suspended do they shoot
you no if you break CRA you just like
like it'll kick you out so what's your
character in Grizzly World I got two I
got one that's my name he like a dop
dealer and stuff like that in the
streets and then I got the other one
called like officer bro stupid oh so
you're a cop yeah so you're just [__]
with people I [__] with people
officer bro stupid yeah so you just pull
it over and like do you have an accent
like
what's the BR stupid accent give it to
me hey loser I got a drugs that you
[Laughter]
wanted you pull up some clips on oh
YouTube yeah yeah yeah do they know it's
to you some people know they like the
fans that watch my my TW my my uh twit
stuff yeah oh so you're you're twitching
hard I was I slowed down a lot were you
getting money off of that I ain't never
really seen those crazy most I seen was
like $2,000 so I just really be doing it
for fun for fun that's so funny when you
do something like that does it make you
realize like damn I could [__] act
for real you know what I'm saying like
if I really needed to I could play I
could play all kind of no because once
like cuz I be bust out laughing I had to
mute my mic and just bust out laughing
oh for sure I couldn't do it bro I
because I I see some of like like T
Grizzly like they'll be doing this like
serious drug deal and [__] and the way
they be talking to each other I'm like
this [__]
is man I've only played story mode on
Grand Theft Auto I've never played
online no it's fine story mode I I beat
that [__] like 10 years ago you know
what I'm saying I can't wait for the new
one yeah six is coming soon so right now
you're on MLB yeah Otani the Asian man
no he ain't on my he ain't on my team
but I [__] T though he's a Dodger now
yeah I was hoping he came to Miami yeah
the shout out to the Marlins I don't
know if they're good or not I don't
really n they they got a nice Squad well
my team's uh need toate they pitching
roster a little bit I'm from Arizona so
the diamond made it to a World Series
which made me care about baseball for
about 2 weeks yeah you know I don't give
a [__] about baseball are you are is
that your that's not your favorite sport
is it is it yeah baseball is yeah I
played oh you played what' you play uh
shortstop mainly short stop is you gotta
be on it yeah yeah were you like how far
did you go uh I had in high school I
could have I could have did some in
college but I one a whole different why
do you think there aren't more um I feel
like the best baseball players come from
everywhere else but here oh like I feel
like there's not a lot of like like when
we think of like uh high school
basketball High School football it's
like a thing but I feel like baseball
for whatever reason it's a lot harder to
get the youth involved why do you think
that is like what got you into it like
no I when I was Ling some friends yeah
but baseball is
real more it's a lot more mental and you
got to really be Reve like it's you got
to be super dedicated to be good at it
right you know what I'm
saying uh and it's a sport
where okay like football if you run the
play okay the catcher got to get to you
I mean the the the quarterback yeah the
center got to get the ball theart the
quarterback and running you got help to
to win a game baseball just you baseball
when you go up there that ball come to
you you got to catch and throw that
[__] you feel me yep you go up
the bat you got to hit the ball or not
hit the ball you feel me so that's what
everybody says about golf
like golf is like golf is [__] boring
see I've never played I couldn't do it
I've only played a top golf in Vegas
where you hit the ball and [__] but my
homies are in the golf and they're like
it's it's like you versus yourself mhm
it's all it is you're you're against the
course who cares if you're playing
somebody like it's really the whole game
is just it's like mental
like fortitude I they could keep golf
it's definitely boring that's crazy
baseball huh so is your your team is the
Marlins u i f with the Marlin I got a p
the Marlins
uh I wouldn't say nobody else is my
favorite cuz I'm more of a like I I'm a
fan of a person like so so your favorite
player Manny Ramirez my favorite all but
him you know he Manny was a beast on the
Red Sox so you were [__] with the Red
Sox then yeah and then we went to the
Dodgers he went to the Dodgers yeah so
right now it's like otani's the guy yeah
he nice it's crazy cuz he I I feel like
he's been the only person since like
Babe Ruth that's been good as good at
hitting as he is his pitching
cuz back in the day Babe Ruth was a
pitcher on the on the Red Sox before he
went to the Yankees yeah uh CE CE B was
a good hitter too I don't remember shout
out to CC I remember CC I didn't know he
was hitting though I didn't know he was
hitting yeah see he I don't think he
ain't get as many as BS Bay Area Legend
right there CC sebastia shout out to him
well T is a a different crazy and he got
the bag and he got paid smart yeah he
kicked all cuz you know in La the taxes
suck M so he's only getting paid $2
million a year and then after his Deal's
over is when all the real money kicks in
and he'll be [__] he'll left La by
then that tax money in C's you doing the
right thing Florida's where it's at no
state tax you could carry a gun you know
what I'm saying you could do whatever
you go to a strip club at 6:00 in the
morning get some chicken wings Mar
probably just ain't have enough for him
yeah hey we got to stop the interview to
tell you about our good folks want to
give a shout out to odd Sox that's right
baby go to odd Soxs official.com they
just celebrated 10 years 10 years of odd
Sox that's right use the promo code
bootleg right now you'll get 20% off all
right look they got all the socks
they're the most comfortable socks in
the world though I actually like to
point out that that's a fact uh well
it's also factually my opinion but I am
telling you you won't find a more
comfortable sock than Odd Socks now the
real key is guys the odd Soxs Basics
these right here here
M these are the only socks on my feet if
you saw me um on NBA young boys couch
with some wet dusty ass snow ridden sock
it was a white Odd Socks
basic the most comfortable sock in the
world they got all the licenses they got
[__] Crush they got Baja Blast Beav
and but head Hot Cheetos Modello I mean
uh Scarface we can go on and on and on
they got the the underwear they got it
all look if you like A1 steak sauce they
got a pair of drawers for that ass go to
oock official.com right now use the
promo code bootle save 20% off a
checkout thank me later also want to
give a big shout out to the good folks
of King pal that's right baby if y'all
don't know about King pal let me tell
you about King pom bro first of all
we're talking about straight raw organic
goodness hand me a box Cyrus hand me a
box give me a box oh my goodness look
what's dope about King pom is no tobacco
straight organic natural Leaf all right
oh we got more oh we got more oh these
are the dragon fruit Kings sizes Jesus
Christ how much King P my [__] God
just King Palms listen that's all we
smoke out of right and they got the
turpine infused tips with that flavor
listen bro the flavor let me just show
you what that looks like like this right
here is some of that blue
grape you know you light that up you
maybe put put some of your favorite
premium
whatever you want in there you know you
light it up you got the tip you squeeze
that bad boy you're getting hit with a
rush of flavor um and right now 50% off
when you go to King pom.com and use the
promo code bootleg they got Grinders
they got uh what else do they got they
got goddamn ashtrays they got all the
all the King Palm leaves in the world my
favorite though right now I do love the
sugar Shan the sugar Shan honey orange
is fire all right right 7-Eleven you can
go get King palom at 7-Eleven you go to
your local liquor liquor store and load
up on King palom it's a clean way to
smoke it's a great way to smoke it's a
natural way to smoke tobacco free
straight leafing it um I will never
smoke out of anything but a king pom for
the rest of my life all right so shout
out to kingp go to King pom.com over
time promo code bootleg save 50% off at
checkout half off what are we talking
about let's get back to the interview
what is do you have a a Miami strip club
you like I've been to most of them I
mean booby trap booby trap's cool it's
just a lot I'm just not a club it's just
a lot going on there I like I like that
a lot going on in Miami period I like
tootsies though TOS tootsies is just
chill you could go sit off in the cut
and have a lobster tail and not be
bothered be so too sedi you get up on
that second floor got security running
around the parking lot harassing and
[__] yeah booby trap's a wild Place yeah
booby trap's fun well I'm just not a
club person I just I'd rather be in the
house playing video games unless you're
getting paid to be there yeah and Anime
what's your favorite
anime my alltime favorite is in
Yasha but I've been locked in to uh
Black Clover I've been locked in my hero
Academia I've been locked in uh the new
bleach bleach yeah I've heard of that my
son I just bought my son the sword from
uh one piece I bought him a sword from
um I'll tell you right now CU I texted
him what's your favorite
anime I bought him I spent like two on
Christmas I brought him this [__]
sword from this [__] anime a sword
yeah it's a
um Attack on Titan oh Attack on Titan it
was good I can't stand how it end it it
was [__] it says his favorite character
is amond and my top anime is Dragon Ball
nuto and Attack on Titan dragon ball one
of my tops too they just don't be
consistent no more isn't there like 30
Seasons how do you like I you know what
is is what you got to think all the
episodes be stretched to like like one
fight will be eight episodes see I
didn't know that yeah you know what is
an anime people don't give credit for it
being an anime is The
Boondocks it's not anime it is it's not
it is it's not see that's it is an anime
I mean if you go off the anime
definition is not what does that mean
it's like Chinese animation it's
Japanese I think no it's not is it
Chinese boond was made by uh Aaron
mcgruer but it's it's it was made very
you've never seen the fights in the
Boondocks that's not anime it's an anime
bro the boondoc is an anime just like
Afro Samurai Samurai is an anime so if I
call car he G he GNA say his feel like
his anime yeah Aaron first of all the
guy who created his name is Aaron
mcgruer you like you like The Boondocks
I love the I got all seasons on DVD me
too season 3 was that was when the
writers left I love all of them season
one and two though I don't think it gets
better I got a radio drop from uh Uncle
Ruckus for real yeah the voice actor was
doing drops yeah like 10 years ago I got
it shout out to Uncle Ruckus AKA is it
safe to say would you say the closest
thing to like a real life Uncle Ruckus
we've seen is Charleston
White
I'm not sure it's
close right he said some crazy [__]
about his own people I'm just like
that's
very I was a little Uncle
rucky might be right he got the ey [__]
that stff he said he got the ey no
offense but you know no but he does he
does have the I didn't even you know
what I wasn't even thinking about that
well I think he really be just doing
that for the social media I don't know
what I've SE I met him before was he
nice yeah I mean listen I've seen a lot
of his content that I think is hilarious
and I've seen a lot of his content that
I think is yeah extremely yeah when I
met him I just told him like I don't
agree with what you be saying but you
say what you want so you know right is
there uh anybody uh for you that you
know you you've
obviously been on the other side of
being a hot new artist who's who's
somebody who's who's come out the last
year that you're just a fan of doesn't
even got to be somebody you know or it's
been some dope [__] coming out lately
like big X the plug is hard yeah I [__]
with big X he's hard bro that Mexican OT
um guess we having some nice beats yes
Mexican OT for sure we got I got uh two
tracks on with OT yeah oh fire we went
hog hunting him and I in Texas for real
yeah we were I told him I wanted to go
we um we were in a
helicopter and the guy lowered
helicopter we put the guns out of the
helicopter just [__] mowing down pigs
that's fine it's on YouTube for real
yeah this [__] is so much fun why you
see that it must not be on your channel
it's doing really well no it's almost
got a million views it's on my channel I
check it out it's fun if you ever go to
Texas I always want to do it but I don't
know if I can you can I I'm an animal
lover no I'm saying because I'm a felon
oh well they didn't ask me any questions
it's Texas bro yeah but if I had to sign
some paper work I can't because if you
lie on there and say that you're not
convict the Felon as a federal hey we
didn't have to sign nothing right no we
just got straight straight to it just
hopped in the helicopter they handed us
a gun check it out then we was mowing
down the went over gun safy yeah just
gun safety yeah okay yeah it's fun just
don't film it don't post no pictures I
mean you know I don't it's Texas I don't
think in Texas I feel like they don't
give a [__] yeah everybody got a gun
yeah with the FED though they don't give
a [__] this is true they trying to lock
up everybody with a gun so you can't
even vote that sucks yeah I don't really
get into all that yeah I don't really
care about it's not your president or
not I always tell everybody this man if
if who's the president has to do with
how successful or happy you are in life
you got the whole game [__] up yeah
cuz I'mma get it no matter who my thing
is if I can't do nothing to change it I
I don't give a [__] about I try not to
[__] about it ex it's like you could
only
control man wake your fat ass up
man
he's a
snore he been sleep for a minute but the
snores kicked in you're I'm
sorry silly that sounded like your
officer
voice that sounded like what's his name
officer what officer BR stupid BR stupid
bro you should do a [__] skit would
you ever like try to do TV or like I
want to do a cartoon that should be
great I can't find nobody to let me do
it
you want to like do you want to like
write it and I want to do a voice oh
you'll find somebody can't find nobody
all you got to do I guess it's easier in
La you got to get an agent on the actor
side and they'll try to pit you for
voiceover stuff how I get an agent I
don't know know some
agents I don't know any agents on the
acting side I'm like the most I mean for
living in La I don't know much on the I
just imagine me doing a Disney movie
that' be
fire you wouldn't even you wouldn't even
have to like uh you I wouldn't tell
anybody like yo it's redo bang just like
your government name yeah here's some of
my examples maybe a couple GTA clips of
you playing officer [__] whatever the
[__] and I think I think it's possible
man yeah how [__] tuni to help you
out [__] yeah yeah
yeah well listen man the album's coming
out when CU I just saw you put the
pre-order up people could pre-order and
try to unlock the artwork the 19th 19th
how many songs I think like 15 but I'm
uh I'm coming right back in like 2 3
weeks you really yeah Deluxe or a whole
new album um a deluxe it how many extra
songs six seven I'm still deide right
now shout out to hey man you got hey I
got a feeling we going to get another
album before the end of the year from
you too I it's [__] January n I'm
trying to get y three this year three
okay last question uh give me your if
you're on it who are the other three
artists on the bat rou hip hop Mount
Rushmore if it's Fredo bang and you you
can exclude yourself if you want but I
I'll leave that up to you I I think I
think I can put enough word game to be
on now okay so Fredo's on it there's
three three more spots on M Rushmore
it's four people me Gates yes uh buy of
course your
cousin and Webby that's three uh you
said baton R
yeah
little fat
okay and dude and dude I wouldn't visit
a dude I
know he's a nice guy and and I also
wanted to commend you guys for the unity
in the community thing was that about a
year
ago I think so yeah about a year and
some change ago which was a big deal m I
was trying not to I was trying to be the
first interview ever where dude wasn't
brought up that you've done but yeah I
don't and he still technically hasn't
been brought up because he's just dude
yeah yeah I listen cuz I I I really you
know I really hate when people bring him
up cuz I feel like it' be unfair cuz I
feel like when y'all not and I'm not
saying this in no type of negative way
I'm just I feel like when they when when
people get even with Gilling though like
I that's why I say I'm not saying it in
a negative way cuz I [__] with y'all you
know I [__] with you personally when
people in interview him they don't be
want to [__] up the chain of of the
interview and stuff so they don't bring
me up to him you feel me I be feel like
it's kind of like you know what my
Approach with that interview was um I
felt
like I have had zero relationship with
him right yeah know I say I understand
but I just say it's unfair in my Cor in
my for me because it be making me look
like I'm always talking about him you
feel me which I know it's just I I know
it ain't that well I think your
and I think both of you guys are like so
mentally mature past whenever you guys
had whatever y'all had that you know
that's why that when I saw you guys did
the community event um with with his
team and your and and your team I just
thought that was a big deal but you know
my approach to that whole situation was
like I don't want to uh do more of what
is expected and that would be bringing
up dirt understand then they probably
would have shut that [__] down soon as
you ask about me I didn't even I see to
to credit to to him it was just him and
I talking right and and and and um you
know uh I just I knew my Approach with
that was
like most people probably talk to him
like he's an alien right but he's just a
dude you know what I'm saying he's got
kids like I got kids like you got kids
like let's just shoot the [__] and and I
I you know I didn't want to get into too
much of that cuz I don't have a previous
relationship with him you know it's cool
though CU I be understand I got a job
and you know what I'm saying it just be
to the fans it make it look like I'm
always speaking on him cuz when they
somebody when the blogs cut something up
it be me talking you know what I'm
saying well look y'all passed it man I'm
a open book so people can get that out
of me you feel me well look y'all passed
it man 2024 new [__] new money finally
new music finally new music finally
January 19th the new album is out yes
I'm sad yeah which I think is a great as
that's that's a hey man look so far it's
been a good year for music cuz this new
21 Savage i s it to you let you hear
hear before it drops have you heard the
new 21 Savage album that dropped
yesterday fire fire he always got some
good production it's oh my God beats man
I look forward to hearing your album
everybody should go him and Drake the
best with grabbing a concept and Ross
Ross got the best beats it's Ross 21
Drake yeah Ross Ross and um Ross's ears
for Beats is crazy Meek their production
was good Meek but as far as the total
package 21 and Drake always know how to
get get a subject wrap a theme around it
and deliver like that [__] the American
dream and all that that [__] is five
well listen your album's coming out on
the 19th everybody go support it if you
pre-order you get the full artwork right
uh Kevin Gates is on
it Rob 49 who else Ross inre so go go
support the album new videos coming
there's a lot going on man so I
appreciate you man yeah Studio we I play
that yeah we'll go over we we'll walk
over to the studio and listen to the new
[__] right now um go support pre-order
hey stop [__] streaming buy the
[__] album on iTunes man I don't why
you streaming too though no but stream
it but also go to iTunes and spend $10
and put some money in this man's pocket
immediately yeah a million streams is
$3800 y'all support the [__] artist
buy the album merch too merch coming you
uh no I'm kind of late with that you got
get that [__] see you're [__]
slipping bro get it together he needs
merch he needs all that [__] merch is on
the way better on the [__] way I'm
get little something put I'm put a the
package together there it is Fredo
appreciate you brother can we show some
love to our family at harden man shout
out to harden man look if you're in
Vegas you got to pull up you got to say
take me to harden right now I need to go
to harden they're going to take you
they're going to get you situated
hardine Las Vegas the best cannabis uh
dispensary I've ever walked into in my
life the most craziest selection of
Premium cannabis in the entire world I
mean that place smells like
God's uh sweat it feels it just smells
so good in there it's just oh they got
their own scent they're our family too
man so make sure you follow them online
Hardin Las Vegas all right shoot them a
follow on uh Instagram also go to Hardin
Las vegas.com and when you're in Vegas
make sure you pull up to harden baby